welcome everybody uh thanks for that
much for coming along today
um i know for many of you you're going
to be potentially stuck at home
uh looking after children doing all
sorts of other things so
the fact that you're able to participate
even though you're not able to actually
fly around the world i think that's
fantastic
i'm going to be sharing with you some
thoughts about micro services
coupling cohesion information hiding and
a whole bunch of other
ideas and and in some degrees these are
kind of old school computer science
ideas but i think in another very real
way they're
they're kind of really important uh
topics and very important uh subjects
for us to look at
and i think we often lose sight of the
things that came before because the
shiny stuff is way more interesting
and so i'm hopefully going to show you
some of the earlier ideas
uh from the area structure programming
that might help you build a better
micro service architecture very quick
bit of background about me
i previously wrote a book about
microservices uh building microservices
that book was released in early 2015.
i'm in the process of working on a
second edition that's at a very early
stages
my most recent book monolith to
microservices was released at the end of
last year this is a deep dive on how we
take systems
and decompose them i was actually just
doing a
did a two-day online class uh maybe some
of you in the audience came alongside
class in which case there's going to be
some overlap
but if you want to know more about the
work that i do i'll see some of the
other talks that i've done in the past
you can find lots of information over at
my website
but we're here today to talk about
microservices as is quite common for me
that's what i end up doing a lot and
when i talk about microservice
architectures i always try to sort of
zero in on the thing that makes them
interesting as an architectural choice
and that one of those key
characteristics that we're often aiming
for with a microservice architecture
is this idea of independent
deployability
so the idea that i can go to a service i
can make a change to that service and
deploy that
into a production environment without
actually having to change anything else
now this is often quite tricky to make
work in practice
one of the things that often comes up
very early on is okay well that's a
great idea
and sure we can talk about things like
zero downtime deployments and all this
kind of
fun techy stuff but it often just starts
with how do you
handle independent deployability when
you consider the fact that microservice
is being used by other people
in other words what about those sort of
upstream consumers of your service
when we think about independent
deployability if i'm going to change the
account service in this situation
i i want to be able to make that change
in isolation
make a change to accounts deploy it into
production
release that functionality to my
customers to the users of my software
without having to change anything else
so that means in this particular
situation
when i redeploy uh version two of the
account service
i need to make sure that the customer
service which is upstream which is an
upstream consumer
of the service that that still is able
to work so i have to maintain
backwards compatibility if i don't
maintain backwards compatibility
when i make a change i deploy that
microservice i could end up breaking my
upstream consumer
which could often have quite
catastrophic effects for a system if
that causes
some kind of cascade of failures so
we've got this idea of a group of
functionality
which uses another group of
functionality and i'm able to change
some of that functionality independent
of other functionality
and still make sure that they all work
together this seems like quite a tricky
problem to deal with
and it can be but luckily we have been
here before
maybe we were here before back in these
1960s
back in the 1960s much of our computing
was done on mainframes we were operated
in a world where we had
a small number of very large machines
that would look
not that dissimilar to this sort of
thing um where you know just because of
how
difficult it was to build computers we
didn't have many of them
and that meant most of our software was
running on mainframe based applications
as the mainframes became more powerful
as advances in computer science allowed
us to build more complicated and larger
uh programs we started realizing that we
needed ways to organize those programs
to make them more manageable
uh some of you today might rail against
your um
sort of single process monolithic
applications before becoming a big ball
of mud
um often that's just the case of you
know not finding ways to structure that
code in the right way
so a lot of work was done back in the
1960s and into the 1970s
looking at how do we structure a program
in order to make larger programs
easier to work with one of the core
ideas that came out of this space is
that time is the idea
of having software broken down into
modules the idea here is that a module
can be worked on
independently at one module can expose
functionality that can be used by a
different
module these modules allow for a degree
of independent working
if i had lots of different developers or
even lots of different teams
i could have some developers working on
module a some other developers working
on module
b and so on and so forth great that
works pretty well
these are modules also would allow some
degree of
reuse depending on the nature of
technology that you're using
you may be able to take say module c and
reuse that in a different
program and this would give us
reusability of functionality across
different programs now modules as a
concept
have been around for a very long time
and but in a lot of our modern
programming languages the concept and
importance of modules
has been reduced somewhat at one level
we have
capabilities in our programming
languages like namespaces or packages in
java
these are ways where you can group code
together and say okay this code is
hidden inside this module
this code is available to another module
another package elsewhere
we could then take those packages those
namespaces
and sort of bundle them together in a
nuget package an npm
a jar file that then gives us the
ability to reuse those modules between
different programs so we have all of the
same building blocks that allow us to
create
modules in our modern programs but we
often don't really use them
in the same way as we used to think
about structured programming
often the way we kind of organize our
code into name spaces
and packages is way too much of just an
afterthought
and it's kind of just an arbitrary
categorization rather than thinking
about
grouping our code into isolated modules
that can be easily changed independently
from each other
nowadays of course we operate in the
world of micro services
and the microservice world has changed
microservices
we are now we can think of microsoft as
now are
as collections of functionality hosted
on a networked endpoint
fundamentally is a module though a
microservice individually is a
collection of functionality
that that now communicates uh with over
networks with other modules
these modules now just happen to run on
different computers
whereas before they're typically on the
same machine now these modules run on
different computers the communication
between those modules
is done via network calls some kind of
network protocol typically
it could be a synchronous on
asynchronous protocol doesn't really
matter too much as
sake of this conversation the fact that
we run these things now separate
processes
typically on separate computers means
that we have a
much easier time of deploying these
things we can deploy them now
independently
whereas typically for modular-based
software before we would think about
including a module into a program as a
static linking activity
i would package all of those modules
together and deploy them as one big
thing whereas now we can kind of think
of our
of our modular architecture as being
modules that can be worked on
independently yes but also deployed
independently
and that's kind of the shift and that's
really come about
because we've got more computers in the
90s we saw a shift
from larger very expensive mainframe
based systems
over to much more cost-effective
server-based infrastructure so now we
had a large amount
of smaller machines rather than a small
amount of large machines
and you can see all the work done around
things like service oriented
architecture
that followed as an attempt to come to
grips with the new economies of
computing
how do we build applications that make
use of the fact that we now have a lot
more computers
um but i think often in all that
scramble we've sort of lost sight
of a lot of the lessons we learned about
building modular software
and i do think that when done right
microservices are just a form
of modular architecture
so this is same way let's talk about
some of the backgrounds to all of this
let's talk about
information hiding so information hiding
was a concept developed by david parnass
back in 1971
and david parnasse was doing some
research looking into
well if we've got these ideas of modules
what's the right way to find a boundary
for a module
how to ensure that one module can be
worked on uh
independently without causing problems
elsewhere so his work published in 1971
really zoned in on this idea of
information hiding
uh and we'll come back to this concept
of information hiding but basically it
entails sort of hiding as much stuff as
possible
inside the service boundary the idea
here
is that if information that's hidden
away can be changed freely
any information that a module exposes to
another module
is something that effectively becomes
part of the contract that that module
exposes
to the outside world and so if we hide
as much as possible
we can change lots of things without
worrying about having
a cascading effect and there's actually
really nice piece
of work done by agent collier agent
collier writes a really good blog called
the morning paper
where he looks back over uh sort of
computer research papers and summarizes
them for
for mortal people and he actually took a
look back at david pardas's
work in this area and he said well what
would happen if we just took the word
module and replaced it with the word
micro service would these papers still
make sense
and you know indeed he found that you
know certainly when looking into the
ideas of information hiding
and the other work that david pines did
in the area of modular decomposition
that actually these ideas do stack up
it's actually quite a nice moment in one
of these blocks where
david pines himself starts leaving
comments
uh on the blog post uh talking about how
his own current thoughts about the
subject
so coming back to information hiding um
so you may well want to go read those
agent collier papers because they're
really interesting but going back to uh
this idea of information hiding the idea
really at one level is quite simple
so here i've got some sort of
microservice here and i've got internal
implementation detail
i've got some external consumer that's
going to make use of the functionality
that my
account service in this example exposes
and that shipping service here can reach
right in and
gain access to some of my internal
implementation details
and that then leads to a bit of a
problem because if i change some of that
internal implementation detail
then that's going to break the consumer
so i might change some
innocent piece of internal detail that
an external party needed
the contract therefore with my
outstanding party has been violated
and i've kind of lost the ability to do
independent deployability
because if i deploy this account service
in this state it's going to break an
existing consumer
with information hiding the idea here is
that you're being quite
explicit about what information you
expose to what functionality
you expose and that is you're being
explicit not only to the person
using your service but also to the
person developing that service
so if you can clearly differentiate
between functionality which is hidden
from the outside world and functionality
which is
shared with the outside world you make
it very easy for a developer to reason
about what information can be easily
changed the shipping service here only
has access to that shared information
if i change anything there i am aware
that i may well end up
breaking that upstream consumer but
anything in that hidden space
that stuff that i should be free to
change without worrying
and so when you're building
microservices one of the earliest pieces
of advice i can give you is
share as little as possible hide
everything you can
and if anything that is part of the
external contract
that you're exposing with an outside
party that should be made
very very explicit to the developer
working or the developers working
on that service sometimes we do things
that make these
what we share not very explicit at all
so here's an example of
and this is this can introduce areas of
accidental breakages
where you'll be making an innocent
change to a piece of code without
realizing that that has an effect on the
public contract
so quite a common pattern i see is
someone taking
say a class definition like this and
mapping it to some kind of json payload
and that's a json payload that's going
to be exposed over a network boundary
and used by another service so in this
example here
we expose a customer from this service
we take that customer object
run it through some kind of json
serializer that's just going to walk the
fields of a given object
and convert that into the mapping to the
json maps version of that
and there are goodness knows how many
libraries out there that will do
something like this for very different
languages and take just
data structures and map them to json
quite straightforwardly now
i'm working as a developer i look at
that customer class and i think hang on
a minute we're storing an age
why would we store the age of a customer
that seems a bit odd
it seems to make much more sense that we
actually store say a date of birth
so i might change that to store a date
of birth unbeknownst to me though
that co that customer object is actually
being serialized and exposed over my
network boundary
so if you now serialize that object
again the age field has vanished
it's now been replaced with a date of
birth field now if i didn't
if i wasn't aware that that customer
object was being serialized
i could accidentally do i could make a
change that customer object very easily
that breaks external parties and i see
this happen a surprising amount
if you're going to do something like
automatically mapping
from a piece of code or data structure
into something like a json structure
i was just making it very explicit to
the developer
make your heavy use of annotations maybe
explicitly mark
fields that will be serialized and make
it an opt-in
and then at least there'll be a visual
cue to the developer that there's
something going on here they need to be
aware of
you might even want to consider doing
something like creating a data transfer
object
this is a pattern that martin fowler
sort of captured
in his book enterprise application
architecture
and it's a the basic idea of the data
transfer object to say is that i've got
my
internal representation of something but
i might have quite a different
external representation so i might have
my customer that i use inside my service
boundary
and see here i've made the decision to
change that customer
field to be a date of birth rather than
the age but i recognize i still have to
expose the age to the outside world
because that's what the people
externally expect
and so i basically create a data
transfer object representing that
customer
and i recognize that that data transfer
object is what will effectively be
serialized and sent over the wire
so that can give you some separation
between internal representation
and external representation and so as a
developer i'm going to have to
explicitly go and change
my customer dto to change that external
representation
and that's something that can that's
going to be a very conscious thing right
you put it in a separate package if you
want to in
in some projects like this i would even
put watches on dto objects to see if
they're being changed in ways that are
backwards compatible or backwards
incompatible so that's kind of really
important right so
being very explicit from a developer
point of view about what can
and can't change going back to some
other work done by david parnass he
talks about this idea that
when we think about modules the
connections between them
are the assumptions that modules make
about each other
so in other words you know a a call that
one module makes to another
basically one module module a that talks
to module b module a has assumptions
of how module b is going to behave the
connections
are effectively the calls that we would
make in say a microservice architecture
implicitly imply we have implicitly
implies definitely redundancy
but they imply we have an assumption
about how that microservice is going to
behave
with information hiding we're reducing
how many assumptions that we have to
make about another microservice or
another module generically the problem
often is that these connections
these assumptions we make about the
modules or the microservices we call
are often purely captured in an implicit
way
we are not explicit about that and i'm a
big fan
where possible of being explicit about
the assumptions you're making where
possible
if you are explicit about the yeah about
what module b
thinks module d should do for example
then it becomes much
easier for you to reason about what
things can change safely and what things
cannot
so what what kind of tools have we got
here
that can help us in terms of being
explicit about
what we expect of another module well
this is actually an
area where schemas can help greatly and
i think it's a bit unfortunate that sort
of in the time since the soa
also the way we're implementing service
oriented architectures
um you know with things like soap and
whistle when that fell out of favor
we seem to have ditched a lot of other
ideas in that space at the same time
wizdl which is the schema format for
soap is not much fun to work with
but we seem to have got rid of the idea
of any schema rather than just
reflecting on the fact that maybe that
schema wasn't great
i actually think schemas are very useful
because they allow you to make an
explicit definition of what a
microservice exposes
that again becomes an explicit
representation for your developer
working on that microservice
as to what they need to maintain to
maintain backwards compatibility
it is also an explicit representation of
the assumptions
that an upstream microservice has of you
i know loads of you are probably sending
json over http
that's probably the most common form of
inter-process communication is some
style
of json over http communication now i
personally am not a big fan of json
for general service to service
communication i think it's fine for a
browser
but i think it's got a lot to be desired
for communication
within a services estate and json
typically is used without a schema
but you do have the option of using a
schema with json
there's a thing called json schema which
although it hasn't got a final version
has a perfectly usable draft um and and
that's uh
that's that's something that can be used
today so you can still carry on using
your json over http but you could also
now optionally have a schema that says
and here is how i'm going to expose
my data and i think that's very useful
very very useful schemas one done well
can also allow you to generate
client-side code that is able to read
those payloads automatically so we kind
of get this benefit of being
explicit about what our our microservice
or our module exposes
but we also get the ability to generate
code
to read those endpoints a great example
of that will be something like the
google
protobuffer specifications this is an
open source serialization
mechanism it's also used inside grpc
and so here on the right hand side here
i see a very very simple
protocol specification this is exposing
kind of the different types
that an end point is exposing um and so
it's very easy for an external party to
now generate code against that
and google proto buffers allow for a
higher degree of interoperability
between different languages
the civilization form itself is also
significantly more efficient than json
in terms of the time taken to serialize
deserialize and transmit
so there may be some other wins for you
there if you're looking for other to
eat other efficiencies out of your into
process communication
one of the nice things around a schema
is that you have
theoretically at least the ability to
compare different versions of a schema
and reason about whether or not the
changes made from one version to another
are backwards compatible and for
something like protocol buffers
we actually have a program and a tool
train to do that there's a tool called
protoloc
which allows you to compare and contrast
two different schemas and say are they
matching
this could be a great thing for your
service if your service exposed some
sort of proto buffer endpoint
you could easily put this into your
build you make a change that protocol
specification
and the build says yes that's backwards
compatible the build passes or no
that won't be backwards compatible and
i'm going to fail the build
and then at least you get some fast
feedback obviously schemas aren't the
only way forward for this
testing also is a huge part of
maintaining and making sure you have
some degree of backwards compatibility
and again good testing could really help
in terms of independent deployability
what i will say is if you don't have
schemas you're likely going to have to
do more testing to get the same degree
of confidence
so i think schemas and testing can
complement each other very very well
in the same way that static typing and
testing can still go together
hand in hand so we've talked a bit about
information hiding and it is a
super super important concept and if
there's only one thing you take away
from the presentation today
should be i should hide as much as
possible all right information hiding is
super super useful
but there's other ideas that we can look
at as well that come from the wider
field
of structured programming these books
are actually surprisingly hard to get
hold of nowadays
i managed to get a copy of the book on
the right the book on the left goes for
about 80 quid at the moment and takes a
long time to arrive so i
i have to say i've relied on online
versions of this book but
um you can find it i think over
archive.org
as part of their lending process anyway
these are some of the seminal books
certainly the structured design book by
jordan and constantine on the left
which outlined a whole other concept
around
how we think about structured
programming and they gave us a whole
bunch of
terms that we kind of now take for
granted two of those terms that we now
take for granted
are coupling and cohesion we talk about
these ideas quite a bit
especially in the concepts in the
context rather of object-oriented
programming
and often as well in the context of
services-based programming
we don't necessarily always have a good
understanding about what these terms
mean
but we tend to know what the desirable
types of these things
are so we talk about wanting low
coupling
and strong cohesion and so that's what
we tend to say we want these things and
we'll talk about why
uh just in a moment so let's talk about
what these terms mean
well cohesion is the kind of idea that
well
there's different definitions don't i
like the best i know where i originally
heard this from
is the code that changes together stays
together so in other words if i've got
all my invoicing functionality that i've
got to change i would like to be able to
change that in one place
keep that code in one place rather than
having to go lots and parts of my code
base to to make that
change happen by having all that
functionality in one place
makes it much easier for me to say uh
fight you know remove duplication create
abstractions
all that good stuff but it also reduces
the amount of work required to make
changes
and then we often might see the opposite
of this we might see examples of weak
cohesion
and we've probably all worked on systems
and maybe distributed systems
where you have to sort of go to like 5
10 15 different
20 different places in your architecture
in order to make a change that software
you know the the invoicing functionality
is spread all over
payroll's in about five different places
and we have to go make changes in like
two
three four five six different services
just to roll out a simple feature
and then when we have our architectures
that have this sort of
weak cohesion that can often lead to
um sort of a much higher maintenance
costs as well
with the services architecture that can
lead us into the world of things like
the distributed monolith
now cohesion kind of goes hand in hand
with coupling and coupling
is the degree to which changing one
module requires a change in another
module
if the if my cohesion is weak um i'll
have to go and change lots of things if
i want to change that functionality i've
got to go and change it in lots of
places
that leads to coupling because i'm
having to change all those things
together
so as we have weaker cohesion we tend to
have
tighter coupling what we want of course
is we want looser lower coupling
so as we reduce coupling we will tend to
find that our cohesion
improves so there's a vicious or
virtuous relationship
there and this actually gives rise to
something that's known as constantine's
law
which states that if a structure is
stable
if the cohesion is strong and the
coupling is low
now remember what we want for our micro
services we want independent
deployability
to have independent deployability we
need a stable
interface so with that in mind
we want a micro services which have a
strong degree of cohesion
and have loose or low coupling with
other micro services
and based on you know these ideas that
should give us a
stable microservice boundary that makes
it easy for us to develop
independently so if you want independent
deployability
information hiding is really really
important as are having
strong cohesion and loose coupling
now coupling is a bit more of a nuanced
concept and it comes up in lots of
different forms i'm going to take you
through a few different forms
and and some of these are terms taken
directly from structured programming
some of them have changed a little bit
i'm trying to work on kind of a
model to describe the different forms of
coupling in the context of micro
services
so this is far from a finished piece of
work but we're going to look
um i think we'll actually skip over
coupling because it's a bit of a
niche one
but we're going to take a look at domain
coupling common coupling
and content coupling and look at how
these different forms of coupling
would manifest themselves in a
distributed system
and maybe talk a bit about how we could
fix those problems
in general when we think about these
different forms of coupling we're
looking to find
looser forms of coupling so domain
coupling over here on the left is a
fairly
loose form of coupling we get over
something like content coupling
which is also known as pathological
coupling
this is where we're getting to really
really tight forms of coupling
so in general when you find a form of
coupling you're going to think well
can i kind of replace this with a
different form of coupling that might be
better for me
that's looser that allows me more
ability to change things independently
we'll start off with the kind of the
easiest one which is domain coupling
and so here's the main coupling so i've
got a service here over on the left
called the order processor
and this is involved in some kind of
process to
reserve stock and take payments right so
this looks like a
sort of orchestrated process to handle
you know on some online e-commerce
company maybe
so i'm talking to a warehouse i thought
we've got some physical inventory going
on i'm taking money
the kinds of things you could imagine an
e-commerce company would need
so the order processor has need to use
functionality in the warehouse service
the warehouse service here
exposes the functionality to allow me to
reserve stock
and the payment service allows me to use
the functionality to take payments which
is kind of what you would expect from a
payment service
the order process here is said to have
domain coupling
with the warehouse and with the payment
the order processor
needs to make use of the domain exposed
by the warehouse
and the domain exposed by the payment
service if the warehouse changes its
functionality changes that part of the
domain changes how
stock is managed for example in such a
way that it impacts that contract
the order processor would also need to
change having some degree of domain
coupling in a microservice architecture
is pretty much inescapable what we've
done with our microservice architecture
is broken things down into
you know this functionality is using
functionality in this micro service over
here
we do need to collaborate with other
micro services from time to time to get
things done
so this is to some extent unescapable
but we can also still take
attempts to limit it so here the order
processor
has a degree of domain coupling to both
warehouse and payment
it's therefore vulnerable if the
warehouse or payment make changes that
change their contract
but there is no domain coupling between
the warehouse and the payment service
they don't talk to each other
there's no communication between them
whatsoever so a change to payment
is never going to affect warehouse
directly and so if you can reduce how
many services that you have domain
coupling on
you're likely going to make it easier to
evolve your services in isolation
um one of the sort of smells you can
look for one of the potential problems
you can look for
are micro services that have lots of
outbound domain coupling
something like an order processor is
often the kind of service that could
well end up talking to about 5 10 15 20
different micro services
so it will have a high degree of domain
coupling to lots of
other outbound services and in that
situation you're always worried that
it's doing too much
that'll tend to maybe that could
sometimes point to a centralization of
logic
but it also means you've got a micro
service which is much more vulnerable to
other changes that might be made in the
system
you'll typically find that micro
services that have a high degree of
domain coupling will often also have a
higher degree of volatility the extent
to which it has to change
because of these other changes that may
be happening in the system so
you always want to be keeping an eye on
those whenever you see a micro service
that look depends on loads of other
things
take a good hard look at it and and you
know in the same way that you would
say look at a god class in a code base
where which might be doing way too many
things and think
is there a way we could maybe uh split
this apart
the next form of coupling we're going to
look at is common coupling
so common coupling is where we have
multiple micro services
that are all depending on some
externally defined
sort of data source so in this example
here i've got stock levels
so these stock levels could be held in
like a redis cache or
you know it could be a database table or
it could be
a file location and the warehouse needs
to read and write from those stock
levels
and the order processor needs to check
those stock levels and we've also got
our forecasting service
over here which needs to also do things
with those stock levels to check how
much
stock we're selling and maybe make
decisions about what we should order
so a common coupling describes a
situation where like
you have a micro service which depends
on an externally defined data set
the issue of course here is that if we
change that stock level service also our
stock levels data source
we're going to potentially impact
multiple different micro services here
um and often with data sources like this
we're allowing direct data access
another example uh uh that could be
similar this would be something like a
data warehouse
you know if you're having all these
services having to push data into a
centralized data warehouse
that's arguably a form of common
coupling although typically that is
mitigated
by the fact that you know you're
typically doing read-only access to
those data warehouses where something
like stock levels where i've got read
and write behavior
we're a bit more concerned about
something like this
the issue of course here is that we're
much you know any changes to stock
levels ends up having quite a
significant
impact on our system and in fact when
you tend to find common coupling
you tend to find like some sort of data
store in the middle of it that's just
never going to be able to change in any
way shape or form
because the impacts of that are too
great so manageable in some situations
but you again really do want to limit
this
where appropriate and actually be maybe
more selective in what data is stored or
managed in this way would be useful
an example of common coupling that you
might find within a program
would be things like shared memory
locations so shared mutable state
so whenever you have a mutable state
that's shared by multiple multiple
different bits of code or different
processes
we have a real issue there because
effectively we can end up with
situations we effectively do in
communication
via these shared memory locations
which can get really nasty so even
within common coupling there are some
forms that are worse
than others the last form of coupling
we're going to look at
is something called content coupling and
content coupling is the worst
form of coupling that you'll see it's
also unfortunately something i still see
far too often so here i've got an order
service
and that order service is manages the
life cycle of a given order
and uh very simplistically here we've
sort of modeled that as
it basically ha uses and
a table inside its own database where it
can manage the state of a row so when i
make a change to an order i'm going to
update that row
okay it's a pretty straightforward
approach one of the ways in which we
allow ensure that microservices can be
independently deployable is we look to
also isolate data we want microservices
to own their own data management
so that means that other microservices
if they want to make a change in state
have to come to that service and say
please can i make a change in this state
so here
i've got the order processor which is
coming to the order service and saying
could you update this order please so
the way this would work is an order
processor would send some form of
request
over whatever protocol it seems fit and
it might say can you please mark this
order into a shipped
state our order service would take a
look at its local data
and say well based on the current state
of this order
based on the request being made that yes
this is an allowable state transition
and i will now move it into a shipped
state
no it's not and it might reject that the
idea being here that the order actually
manages
the set of allowable state transitions
around a piece of data
and so that kind of can encapsulate the
logic and
state of this service of course we could
do something fancy like running an event
source system in here if we wanted to
but
you know let's keep things simple with
tables and so the nice thing about this
is that we have a single source of truth
for where we get our order information
it is the order
service and we go to the order service
to request the information we want
by going to an explicit service
interface to ask for information about
an order
we actually ensure that the microservice
the order microservice
exposes only what limited data it needs
to it can hide a lot of the detail in
that database
that no one else needs to know about
there might be other things it needs to
track to do its job
no one else in the outside world should
know or care about that
but oh no along comes the warehouse
service and the warehouse service for
reasons we don't fully understand
has direct access to the order services
database
so it can now directly read order state
from that database
it is also able to make changes to that
date state maybe by saying
okay this order is now in a picking
state so picking is the process by which
people go at a warehouse
pick things up and put them into boxes
at this point
we've completely bypassed information
hiding we are no longer available to
decide about what information is hidden
from the outside world
everything in our database is
effectively now shared
it's completely unclear to us now when
working on that order service
as to what parts of our database can be
changed easily
you know we may even have challenges
here about doing things like
adding new database constraints because
we know we're aware that we've got this
other warehouse service out there that
has this connection straight into our
database
we mentioned before that the connections
between modules also kind of define the
assumptions that modules have of other
modules
well here the warehouse has a connection
to our database
so the warehouse clearly has
expectations it has assumptions about
what functionality we should be
providing to that warehouse
but it is completely implicit to us how
can we be explicit about what we think
the warehouse needs
the only thing we've got to go on maybe
is the structure of our database and
that's not a great
schema in this context the other problem
with this model
is that we might have logic and code
inside the order service that says
these things are reliable state
transitions this is the logic
about how this object this entity is
allowed to change these are the set of
allowable
you know state transitions that you can
have but if we allow people to bypass
that logic and go direct to the database
either they've got a duplicate
implementation
of that same functionality in which case
we're lacking cohesion
or they've got a different
implementation in which case we're in
the world where we might have
inconsistent data
our data being updated in inconsistent
ways
there's a reason that this form of
coupling is called pathological coupling
when you reach directly into another
services implementation
like this and reaching directly into
another services database is the worst
form of that
this is a very very tight form of
coupling
and the right fix here would be to get
the warehouse to rather than going
straight to the database
would actually be go to maybe an
interface exposed by the order
that could be a rest-based api or an
invented endpoint or some other
exposed or cue or something else
don't bypass the information hiding and
go go to a well-defined
service interface and you'll be better
off so just to summarize
there are different forms of coupling
out there when you encounter these
different forms of coupling
what you're going to try and do so drag
them from the right to the left
if we loop if we make our coupling if we
sort of decrease
the amount of coupling we have we are
going to make it much easier for us to
make
our software independently deployable so
when you encounter these ideas when you
count say content coupling or common
coupling think
can i get that functionality and change
it in such a way that now maybe it's
using domain coupling
or perhaps even remove the relationship
altogether
so just in summary uh information hiding
is
super super important okay
it's vital that you kind of hide as much
as possible
anything you expose when you excuse to
expose some information this could be a
piece of data this could be a method
expose that in a way that makes what
you're exposing very
explicit strongly consider the use of an
explicit contract to say
this is what i'm exposing having an
explicit declaration about what you
expose
is going to be useful for clients that
are using your service it's also going
to be super useful for people
who are developing on that service
because they understand
what things can be safely changed and
what things cannot
so whatever mechanism makes sense for
you look at maybe doing
you maybe look at dtos if that's going
to work for you look at something like
explicit schemas
annotate any classes that are used in
serialization
all of these are things that can help
tests can also be part of that
but i think you can do more than just
adding tests to this sort of thing some
coupling when you get into it is worse
than others
um common coupling and that sort of
pathological
content coupling is really bad so if we
can maybe shift that multiples domain
coupling
will make our coupling looser we
therefore make independent
developability
much easier as well along the lines
we'll actually end up making this
our systems have a higher a higher
degree of cohesion which in turn should
actually reduce our maintenance costs
which is
a lot of what this is all about but
information hiding
low coupling and strong cohesion all of
these ideas build up to giving you
that idea of independent deployability
i hope this was of use i didn't want to
keep you too long
i've got a lot more information over at
my website including information about
my latest book and the services i offer
and you can find lots of that stuff over
there i will get the slides for this
talk uploaded there shortly
but we do have a little bit of time left
for questions i believe
so i think i will just exit the
sharing from this um so let's
stop streaming take a look to see if
we've got any question
okay so let's
take a quick look at this so we've had a
question here from denise lounge
so janiece uh says and i am going to
apologize up front
if i get that your um if i get the terms
your terms your name's wrong um so i've
heard talk about
high cohesion low cohesion not strong
weak either a semantic difference or
just different wording
the strong weak cohesion is the terms
that were originally used in structured
programming
and so because i'm trying to sort of
unify that work
a little bit i'm trying to use the
original terms here but you can consider
them as being the same concepts
so you can think of them as a spectrum
so high cohesion you can consider to be
the same as strong cohesion
low cohesion the same as weak cohesion
i'm sort of trying to go back to the
original terms at the moment purely
because
i'm spending so much time reading books
from the 1970s that switching my
brain patterns is proving to be
difficult um
uh so you've mentioned you're not really
a fan of jason as the communication
between services what would you
recommend as an alternative and why
well so why am i not a big fan of json
well firstly it doesn't require a schema
yes you've got json schema that helps
but it's not you know
the fact that most people don't use it
with jason
is a problem the second thing is what is
json being compared to people picked up
jason
largely because they thought it was less
for both than xml
now we can put aside the fact that
actually once you send it over the wire
and compress it it's not much smaller
than xml um
secondly why do you care about how
verbose it looks it's not there for a
human being to read it's there for a
computer to read
so by all means use json for
configuration files
but by and large we really like to print
to pick serialization protocols or
sometimes encodings
some people refer to them as things that
are easy for a computer to create
and another computer to read and json is
alright for that but there are other
forms that are much more efficient
so protocol buffers for example are
significantly more efficient to
serialize deserialize and read
also something like protocol buffers has
significantly better support
built in for enabling you to make
reasoned decisions about making payloads
backwards compatible by all means use
json for human readable things if you
want to
or although i think yaml is slightly
better for human readable
configuration stuff or but i would tend
to restrict the use of json to
communication
to to kind of the front so your front
end devices
are better serialization mechanisms that
i'd be more interested in using
protocol buffers i'd also look at avro
avro effectively is sort of a json based
protocol but
actually has explicit schemas and has
some really nice interesting support
for uh sort of almost like interpreting
different payloads using different
versions of schemas
so i could actually write effectively
something they can interpret uh
payloads from multiple different
versions of the same avro schema
almost using sort of binding to uh
payloads a bit like i'd sort of handle a
dynamic type
um so have a look at avro as a
serialization format that's quite
heavily used in messaging
or protocol buffers and by the way
there's no reason why you couldn't
theoretically send those things
over a http or rest based interface
the other thing you could potentially
look at is maybe look at something like
open api specification so this is uh not
replacing the serialization format but
is at least giving you a way
to define a a schema for a rest based
interface that'd be making use of json
as a serialization format
so the question is one last question
here and we'll take a break the way you
describe it it seems that content
coupling and
common coupling are similar is the
difference the persistence mechanism
content coupling is about a shared
database while common coupling is about
shared state in a more volatile fashion
not quite the distinction is is a bit
kind of less well defined than i would
like uh content
so common coupling is where you've got a
common let's say the content coupling
so common coupling is where you have a
common externally defined data source
that multiple people access
so you say this thing loads people can
access go at it
so that would be your traditional shared
database everyone can access that
common couple as a content coupling on
the other hand
is where you reach inside of somebody
else's implementation detail
so there's there's a subtle difference
so when you with common coupling you
typically say this is a common data
source
everyone could do what they want with
that common data source it is a
free-for-all content coupling is by
reaching into somebody else's
implementation detail so that's the
distinction i'm still working through
those models trying to come up with some
better distinctions
it's a weird thing that a lot of those
distinctions are much more stark when we
look at it in code form than we look at
in services form
so i'm still working through those
models the key thing is
they're both not great but reaching
inside
another services implementation into its
database is worse
often because we're bypassing a lot of
logic around how that data should be
managed
but i i can understand the overlap there
all right we are at time um thank you so
much for coming along
and asking questions so um i i've seen
familiar from some familiar faces on the
attendee list as well so thanks for
coming on some of my talks again
um if you want to know more about my
anything i do you can pop
over to uh uh sort of um
the uh hd drop over to my website which
is just samuel
io you can also find me over at sam
newman
uh if there are any questions i didn't
get to i am going to be on this slack
channel
and i'll be hanging around there for the
rest of the day so thank you so much for
your time